okay so I do want to talk about some
housewives still got some guys I am NOT
doing this you guys we've got I'm
stopped
bravo Bravo 10 Bravo I'm out I'm not
doing it why don't we see that at the
dinner will we get it in flashbacks oh
okay okay so it does that become its own
sort of storyline it plays when it is
relevant to play gotcha okay and and the
Brandi Glanville of it all we know she
comes back we know she's in the mix how
soon do we get that cuz it does feel
like we're setting up to go on somewhere
she makes her first appearance in
episode 10 and right now we're on
Episode like five or something so come
on is there seat do they get a lot of
episodes yes they have a lot of episodes
I feel like they might have 20 or
something there's a lot going on this
season it's a whole energized show and
people are really loving it and the
ratings about but I wonder and I think
I've heard of to talk about this a
little bit how this whole thing is
affecting production Potomac in Beverly
Hills is on the air New York's on the
air but Orange County was shooting was
Dallas shooting salad and just about to
shoot Jersey had just started shooting
so there's obviously been a pause we
have OC was kind of in the middle of
their season almost so there's been a
pause they've been shooting some stuff
themselves but we're anxious to start
getting them all back together obviously
but you know we have to wait and
respectively respectfully watch and see
when it's safe to do it is it is it ever
a thought like maybe we just kind of
scrap what we already shot and start
from quarantine on because you know life
is so different rates tough shot so I
wouldn't want to lose anything that we
shot you know what we shot or the
building blocks of of where the next
season will go so I definitely I don't I
don't think we want to lose anything
what about Salt Lake where where were
they thought lake was wrapped so we're
they're done action on Salt Lake yeah
so when are we gonna get Salt Lake watch
this base I kind of said that like Tamra
Barney did you do you go to Bass Lake so
we have Beverly Hills and we have New
York on right now are you at all
surprised that that Dorinda is getting
some blowback because we all love kooky
and crazy Dorinda but it does feel like
Dorinda is a little dark right now yeah
I'm not surprised I think she was not in
a great place this season you see that
and she's dealing she's got a lot of
anger that doesn't necessarily I think
on the show it looks like she's just so
mad at Tinsley but when you take a more
global view of what's going on in her
life I think you'll see that she's got
more going on that she's upset about
you're not can she redeem herself like
where does she go from watching yeah
okay never count out Dorinda never get
any what a help getting it I am all over
this Atlanta virtual reunion just the
fact that your bond is here and me I saw
the previews to part three and it looks
like linnethia leakes has exited the
building the computer is closed right so
what I mean what's to come does she stay
gone does she come back do we get any
sort of resolution you know uh I don't
know if I want to give that away but I
will say the converse say there are some
surprises in part three and look I'm
always disappointed when people leave
because if the whole point is that we're
there to talk so why are you running off
wait right I mean the weird thing is she
was coming into the reunion in such a
good place she had such a great second
half of the season she made amends with
everybody I mean she has a great song
out so she came into the reunion in a
really great place I think but didn't
enjoy it what surprised you about this
reunion I mean I feel like we got
another iconic line add whoa couple
iconic lines but but candy with I'm
embedded in you
like Portia saying that her boobs were
social distancing great I almost passed
out I think that what I was surprised
about was just how entertaining it was
and it really that reunion is really
just of this moment that we're all in
right now I mean it was it is just very
much of this moment I'm very proud of it
and excited that we did it all right so
let's talk about radio Indy and Sirius
XM this this this live theater I've
heard a couple of the other ones you've
done so where did the original idea come
up with to do like a live episode of a
housewife show well I mean it's
something that I've been wanting to do
since we launched radio and E which is
do theater radio and E theater and then
when we start thinking about things that
we could we could present it just seemed
hilarious to do Housewives episodes and
there are so many fans of the show who
are famous and funny that you know
casting them has been a total joy and
now we've got Cheri Oteri and Kristen
Johnston and Rachel Harris and Phoebe
Robinson I mean we have some group we
have a great cast
not to mention Michael Rapaport as
Dorinda I mean it's hilarious how do you
pick like which episode you're going to
reenact because of course their iconic
episode usually how to pick an episode
where they're all under the same roof
that usually seems to work really well
so if they're all in the Berkshires or
on a trip somewhere those episodes are
really good and and here we are at
Ramona's house in the Hamptons and all
hell breaks
seemed like a perfect way to go New York
is the gift that keeps on giving it
really it really is there's a vibrator
in the chicken Oh
[Music]